[Music]
all right welcome to the last lecture of
the year or for you the tenth lecture of
the year different year um well we got
two more days of celebrities dying so
let's cross our fingers okay that the
right ones do this is 21st century chess
if I'm not mistaken which I probably am
this is the last one I'd say change in
the schedule yeah yeah they're changing
everything there's going to be a new
lecture at this time next week on
something else by somebody else so who
cares the lecture subject today is
maximilian lu and at one point about a
year ago year and a half ago less than a
year ago he was the youngest us master
ever which is sort of like being the
best hockey player in idaho and since
then it's been broke at at least once I
think there's a nine-year-old
three-year-old as a master our
three-year-old or something I don't know
anyway uh every year he goes to the
world's youth which has been renamed to
the world cadet and there's a tournament
for older kids now called the world
youth confusing everybody
and several times he's played in the
world under a and the world under ten
and I think he played in the world under
twelve this year although he might have
played the world under ten and he lives
on the west coast
he's currently 11 years old he's the
highest rated eleven-year-old in the US
he's top ten in the world for his age
and his USCF rating currently is
approximately 20 to 80 I don't have a
lot of games that he played recently
because it's hard to find games of small
children on the internet and in
databases if you do want to find games
of small children you go to chess - d be
calm and all the kids games are there so
I found the best games that he played
although some of them he was 7 to 8
years old at the time so ok now the
first one is interesting especially for
our weaker players of the audience
and at home because white
fell into a trap that I was teaching my
chess camp this week and I remember
after teaching it one of the students
fell into it like five minutes later so
he learned real fast okay just like you
will at home okay and here white played
the well-known blunder Bishop III
developing pieces don't do that okay
now of course white is seven years old
so I'll give him a break okay and what
this does it puts the bishop at night in
the kind of position or a pawn can fork
them and we see this often in this kind
of structure and often in double King
pawn structures Maximilian Liu was quick
to take advantage plays d5 and then D
for winning a piece and normally I would
end things now because you win a piece
but it's the under eight so you can
still toss a coin and it's not clear
who's going to win it's sort of like you
to come to our chess club and you play
chess downstairs winning and losing a
queen doesn't mean very much okay most
of the players here have yet to attain
beginner status and most of them are
here right now watching my lecture
okay so Bishop retreats and we get a
position where blacks a piece up the
reason I like this is black didn't say
oh I'm a piece up I think I'll just take
a nap now he is 70 should take a nap
okay but instead he played war tactics
it even trickier and so white had
nothing left so in this position
g3 a terrible move he played the move
rook GA I always tell my students and
onlookers and my homeless friends when a
rural II the same people the rook and
the Queen are lined up is that good for
the rook or the queen now the audience
doesn't know is good for the rook so the
Queen should be like I don't like that
rook opposite my queen but again this is
the under aid so they don't care about
nothing so King G to solid overlooking
[Music]
well what's the move ninety four and you
can't take the knight because you lose
your queen you could
okay so black is playing more tactics
gray okay and the game continues
unfortunately
okay now c3 is pretty weak
whoa it's weaker than I thought Wow and
we're attacking it so black never lets
up black doesn't say all that material
I'll just stop thinking he keeps playing
more and more tactics because he's a
little kid
that's what he does okay Queen c7
strange move white trades Queens to make
sure he loses the quickest okay because
you don't want to you know you're too
many good moves and the game ended in
sort of a funny way I mean funny if you
have the black pieces rugby one notice
if black plays rook takes tonight which
most of you would play then checkmate
coming soon and when my son was four
this was a typical game that he would
play he would take everything
his opponent would have one rook or one
Queen left and then mate was coming then
my son started playing h6 and h5 and
then he stopped getting made it okay
instead he can win the knight but not by
taking it by playing so many good
answers bishop efore pinning the knights
of the rook so even though black one
apiece really quickly he kept playing
more tactics as the game continued
because they worked and because he was
seven you know he was like oh boy I got
all these tactical tricks and that was
it a World Championship that was in the
United Arab Emirates I was actually
there I don't think I was coaching I
think I cooked them the next year maybe
I coached him there okay thank you for
coming now all right
more brilliant wins for maximilian lou
again jew okay and this is actually very
nice this is actually the same
tournament notice that black is in check
something my chess campers never notice
their kings they're in check ten twenty
moves in a row okay
black played the obvious move King h8
now in a very strange happenstance white
play the best move and it
not easy to find I was shocked I've
never seen by play the best move I
couldn't believe it
never in all my years rookie 7 can be
played and there's nothing wrong with it
but there's actually a slightly better
move
I think after rookie 7 I can play Knight
f5 I think I can play that but you're
2/3 correct which is normal in my class
how's that 2/3 correct that's correct
yeah anybody who gets the right answer
doesn't have to learn fractions all
right Claudia said the right answer then
shook his head so say it again yeah
Queen e7 best buy test now the truth
hurts
white threatens Queen takes Knight May
and Bishop takes Knight mate if you play
work to g8 you lose for lots of reasons
the main reason is Bishop takes Knight
check and your rook is overworked so a
queen e7 is a really nice move for
somebody who is either 7 or 8 because
that's sort of like a creeping move
that's like a Karpov move Queen 7 what I
would never play Queen e7 even if I was
showing the position now
okay so black traded which was correct
now good luck playing black so black
played rook ga and white said yum yum
yum Knight f5 in okay here black ended
up losing because he took one of the
bishops he was down the exchange for
nothing and he lost due to the brilliant
technique of a young man but I was
really impressed with Queen e7
especially when I turned my engine on it
said Queen e7 was the best move I was
like what okay
proving he was using a computer to cheat
no I'm kidding
okay also in the same tournament he was
playing another American player that's
one of the problems we have in the World
Championship it's a world championship
and you're trying to get medals for your
country but sometimes the best players
are from our country so they get paired
so there's nothing you can do and in
fact
they don't do anything to not pair them
it's actually illegal in feed 8
tournaments to do that although in the
1970s 80s 90s and 2000's that was always
done in the US they always changed the
pairings to pair the right people and
feed I said you can't do that you can't
say well he needs a foreign GM to get a
GM norm so we're going to pair him with
that guy you can't do that
you got to just make legal pairings so
occasionally Americans play Americans
there's nothing we can do so we have Lou
versus woo okay and the winner of the
game said woo hoo because you'd know who
his opponent was and he lost look at
that job later ok in fact Logan was at
our chess club here two weeks ago
playing in a tournament I saw him here
and you know who else was playing
Rochelle woo and singeing woo not
related to Logan woo but they're brother
and sister and and Rochelle woo I did a
lecture on her even though you'll deny
it very recently right yeah Rochelle woo
yeah you don't even deny it
well you denied something else I did
okay here white played an amazing move
confusing his opponent and me he played
the longest move on the board so I give
him a hint but enough to know how to
play chess to get it what's the longest
move what's that
Bishop be a confusing the audience yeah
and black was like Bishop B it doesn't
do nothing and in fact this position if
you put it on an engine says it's equal
and black can play reasonable moves and
be equal such as a five stopping night
before check or Bishop c8 so the king
can escape to b7 and the bishop might go
to e6 r a5 instead black was very greedy
as most eight-year-olds are that he went
nom yum-yum rook takes g2 overlooking
the opponent's threats and again this is
what I like about Maximilian Lou when he
has a winning position he doesn't say oh
I'm winning now I'll just play boring
and way
he wins the quickest way the most
accurate way night before check and now
black has a problem the King doesn't
have any squares if King goes to
whatever square that is c5 I seem eaten
- maybe there's a quicker mate but I
doubt it and so he didn't do that
my king b6 and white played the obvious
rook to d6 right bishop c6 loses a piece
so he played King a5 maybe he thought he
was safe here yeah ok and now white made
a move shocking everybody here
man I bet you'd shock black if I was
black am i pointing to this I'd be
really unhappy I would know that they're
crazy or they're winning usually when
they're higher rated they're winning so
then you're like oh it's the one move
you would never play that's the winning
move rook takes a six this ship c7 check
rook takes a six and Bishop c7 check
yeah they both win then Rick a six check
a move I would never think of obviously
he could take first but that would his
opponent he gets sick then so he did
that rook a six root K six isn't
necessary but that's the way when you
play the guy again they're like oh man
that's the guy who played rook a six
against me so then yeah whoa yeah and
again when I'm playing small children I
trade all the pieces I get to an ending
where I'm slightly better can you see
that
can you zoom in slightly better and
that's look and then they blunder I move
seventy five and I win when you decide
I'm better than a seven-year-old I'm
going to play tactically and beat them
that's not good seven eight year-olds
are good at tactics at long positional
endings usually not so good I'm the
opposite my tactics are suspicious but
if the game's 90 moves that I'm slightly
better I can put the old man clamps on
so rook takes a six check there b3 check
black played the best move King a
three-night c2 check black played the
best move and Bishop a d6 check the
truth hurts so I think black regrets
taking this pawn on g2 and you can see
why white was the youngest master ever
in the u.s. sacrificing all this piece
is the ending to made his opponent and
the truth hurts so it's funny how I
explained this to a lot of people but
they don't understand usually they think
when player a plays player B
and player a is better than player B
that the reason they're better is they
get an advantage out of the opening then
they increase their advantage through
the superior play and eventually player
B succumbs to player a's great play what
usually happens when player a beats
player b is the position is about equal
player a never makes a blunder employer
B blunders once or twice a game and when
player B blunders player he goes oh boy
in this position if black had played
Bishop c8 or a5 the computer says it's
equal and after Rick g2 black has to
resign because his King just gets
totally crushed of course a5 prevents
night before or the drunken night a4 and
bishop ca allows the king to escape but
it was an end game black had a rook on
the seventh rank and he was very happy
to take everything he didn't think it's
an endgame I'm getting it made it but he
should have been thinking that by the
way this end of the game reminds me of
your favorite game because smart off
topalov the famous game was at 99 and
you said yeah like you knew I liked that
yeah do I believe him which I believe
you no no no even you don't believe you
yeah anyway in that game Kasparov
sacrificed all his pieces and Thapa
loves King ran up the board and
eventually because part of one so that
was a very nice unfortunately it was
against an American boo okay and least
but not last we have this game this is
from the World Youth in 2014 this was
South Africa okay that's why I like to
be a coach that I get to a different
country every time okay and I think this
was South Africa 2014 pretty sure anyway
white is a pawn up because I said so I
counted the pawns before the lecture
good prep seven to six and in my opinion
you may disagree White's open rooks are
on the D file and blacks Turks are
behind
on so I like white spawn advantage and I
like the fact that White's rooks are
better than blacks okay now here black
played a very risky move Knight g5 he
wanted to put pressure on e4 possibly
sacrifice a piece and attack the white
king this is actually very funny this is
a very complicated example of overworked
now if you go to the world's youth or
you go to a kid's tournament a
Scholastic tournament the Nationals or
you look at the feed a ratings that's
very misleading most of the kids who
have feed a ratings have played very few
games that are feed aerated just like
you okay and Claudio 2,200 USCF how many
feet everything is we played in the last
three years
not many yeah so if you play eight games
litter feed a rated and 200 games that
are USCF rated your feet a rating is not
very accurate so you can see here
maximilien luce 1700 his opponent 2,000
but that doesn't mean his opponents
better than him that means his opponents
probably played a lot of feed a rated
games and he hasn't so normally in the
world's youth the u.s. players getting a
lot of rating points because they don't
play a lot of feety rated tournaments
they play a lot of USCF rated
tournaments and it's changing over the
last few years that tournaments are
rated both ways but still for the most
part for every fear rated game they play
that by 20 USC F rated games their
feeder ratings aren't accurate for
example there's a kid that I coach every
year
who's a V Friedman's private student
she's 2040 USCF and she's fifteen
hundred feet a she's played maybe 40
feet away games in her life and maybe a
thousand feet USCF so her feeding
ratings not accurate so when she plays
in the World Youth a feeder reading was
up a lot okay so in this position white
did something that I love to teach
because it was featured prominently in
one of my favorite games with Fidel care
I see menace which I'm sure you've all
memorized that they didn't memorize it
okay and that game it was called
removing the guard and overworked this
position it a big surprise to the
audience this rook is overworked it's
doing two things it's stopping rip d7
and it's defending the pawn on c5 and
white took advantage of that by playing
what move Knight takes e5 not only does
that win a pawn if black was going to
sacrifice on e4 sound or not he's not
anymore
now not only did white win a pawn white
can take this bishop Y can play rook d7
anyway okay so black took tonight and
now black made an unusual decision but
since he's a small child it's not that
unusual I would move my queen away and
then I would lose may he's getting
crushed over here maybe actually his
decisions better maybe resigning is
better because rooks hanging to and
Knight c5 was better than I thought
what's funny is in this position black
is defending against Knights e5 but it's
not a threat this is called the ken west
syndrome and Grandmaster Ken West is
currently playing in Vegas and getting
recognized he was posting on Facebook
I'm walking in Vega so they're like
you're Ken West and he like yeah you're
V Ken West and he's like I'm a Ken West
yeah so Ken West and Mike comer
irrespective of their playing ability
get recognized all over the country
because of our videos and that was
calling saying his ability that was
something okay I shouldn't lie so much I
can't run okay so here since this pawn
is defended ken west would tell me that
pawns defended I don't even think about
anymore then he moves away the defensive
piece and he's like oh you know that's
right
darn okay that happens to him all the
time and wow it's strange to look at the
move Knight takes e5
when you're down upon and you're trying
to get play this is what I like about
Maximilian loo he doesn't care what the
material situation is he looks for the
most incisive correct move
he doesn't say like oh I'm winning I'll
just be really careful like I would do
he plays like he's a little kid why does
he do that oh yeah that's right he's 9
okay so Knight takes e5 rib d7 Black has
a lot of pieces hanging so he played
rook c7 and now he has a rook at a
knight for a queen not quite enough and
White has two extra pawns h4 again a lot
of players including me are afraid when
they're playing because I'm winning and
I know I'm winning I don't want to allow
any tricks so the move that allows the
least number of tricks is Bishop takes
g5 if my opponent has no pieces they
have no tricks but this kids 9 you'll
care about that he like calculates
figures it out and plays the best move
his opponent place for tricks rook takes
e4 and the computer says y can just play
pawn takes rook and then after taking on
e4 that's not sufficient to defense but
he just took the night and now he's
threatening the rook rook e to check
King F 1 rook takes pawn trades the
rooks and as you can see White has a
queen for a ruck so in junior chess
there's very little resigning I see
games where the players are 2,000 2,200
2,300 and they played so mate sort of
like little kids do when they're down to
Queens in a rook or downstairs in our
club when anybody's playing but here
black actually resigned now it's funny
about that is when I'm coaching the
world youth and a kid wins a game our
kid and I'm looking at his game he has
like an extra Queen an extra rook and
I'm lying I and he's like no let me show
you the rest and I'm laying will you up
a queen in a rug
he's like yeah watch this mate that I
did
okay so I know certain players like John
fedora wits and Gregory Kai Donna
they don't want to see any of that when
you're up a queen and your opponent's
not resigning a lot of grandmasters are
like why are you showing me this like
your upper queen but kids love to
actually like when their pawn doesn't
resign they get to really checkmate them
in this position black is rated over two
thousand and he's down a queen for a
rook so he resigned actually the
opposite colored bishops helped white
because Y can start an attack on the
dark squares and this Bishop and this
rook aren't going to defend and a queen
and a bishop are pretty convincing and
checkmating a king when there's no
defense so one of the few instances at
the world youth somebody actually
resigned when they're supposed to I
would never resign but I'm different I'm
not a youth player so so those were some
of Max's best games that he played at
world youth tournaments he also likes to
play at the national high school and I'm
sorry 90 national high school national
junior high school and the super
nationals which I believe are next year
well for you this year yeah I think
they're coming up the super nationals
not to scare the adults in the room and
you will be scared it's where they take
all the Nationals and put them in one
room at the same time they do it every
four years they get between five and six
thousand kids and it's in one room at
one hotel so if you want to eat at that
hotel good luck if you want to find your
board good luck if you want to not
orange the parents and coaches you hate
good luck you're going to run into them
if you want to find what floor you're on
now okay I I've been I've been to one
once it was scary I wasn't even playing
because I was 40 years too old but those
are scary events and Maximilian Lou is
always fighting for first place in his
grade in his section in the super
nationals and at the world youth he's
going to win a medal soon I don't think
he's won a medal yet but he's been
really close fourth place fifth place
they give medals to the top three and
he's one of the top 10 players in the
world for his age every year he almost
always goes to the
world youth and I think is going to win
a medal soon so replay this video after
the next World Youth which I believe for
him is going to be in Brazil so I'll see
you guys from Brazil and I was talking
it earlier and I told him about all the
Brazilians and he said how many is that
okay now that was a George Bush joke but
alright see you guys next year 2016 it
was nice knowing you but let's go to
2017 bye everyone
hey hey
[Music]
you
[Music]